si técnicamente dame y lamentablemente
está esta negociación fue hecha por
videoconferencia lo cual privó a los
interlocutores de la lógica del cara a
cara es dable lo bueno es que estas
negociaciones continúan que continúan
buscando algún tipo de acercamiento
sobre todo por la cuestión humanitaria y
principalmente para lograr que desde el
punto de vista del gobierno es el esquí
que
aminoren los bombarderos sobre las
ciudades para evitar justamente la el
sufrimiento de los civiles ucranianos
sin embargo los objetivos de rusia son
muy claros y tienen que ver
evidentemente con la remoción del
gobierno o eventualmente con un rediseño
de una paz que no parece ser aceptable
por parte del gobierno es el esquí y en
eso no hay empantanamiento pero sí hay
este ciertamente como bien dijo usted
avance muy lentos y en qué puntos
debería acceder entonces cada una de las
partes para que se se pudiera lograr
alguna
lo más complejo para ellos es lograr lo
que quiere el gobierno de ucrania que es
el repliegue de las fuerzas de rusia a
una etapa previa al 24 de febrero y el
gobierno por otro lado de rusia ya
quiere por escrito una serie de
reaseguros que van desde prácticamente
una neutralización de ucrania como un
factor de relevancia político y
económico para europa y por otro lado es
la plena y la plena independencia vamos
a decir de las regiones del dogmas que
son las que las quin las por las cuales
iniciaron este este conflicto armado por
lo tanto es muy difícil de lograr y ahí
están trabado las posiciones y ha
hablado usted de una posible retirada de
las tropas rusas precisamente el
resultado de la ofensiva rusa sobre el
terreno podría afectar a la aceleración
o la dilatación en el tiempo de este
proceso negociador yo
exactamente la posición de la el
resultante de una negociación política
tiene mucho que ver con lo que sucede en
el campo de batalla hay dos formas en
las cuales este conflicto termine o
porque una de las partes vence a la otra
o porque las dos partes se agotan y no
pueden seguir combatiendo y eso va a
tener que ver con el resultante de el
conflicto a que voy con esto básicamente
de que estamos en el momento en el cual
la guerra de desgaste llevada a cabo por
parte de ucrania está en su pico a
partir de acá ya han empezado a ver
señales muy concretas de que hay
agotamiento de agua agotamiento de
provisiones de alimentos y
principalmente de armas y que rusia a
pesar de las pérdidas que dice el
gobierno que daña que han tenido y que
el gobierno de rusia no nos reconoce si
ha sufrido de manera sostenida pérdida
de equipamiento pero al mismo tiempo
contiene un avance más lento pero
continúa avanzando sin dejar lugar de
ucrania sin atacar por así decirlo
entonces realmente todavía estamos no
tan cerca o no estamos tan cerca de
alcanzar el acuerdo que traiga una nueva
paz a la región